this is Charlie Hall hi I'm Charlie Hall
this is Charlie halls kitchen I make a
fabulous coffee this is where Charlie
Hall sleeps this is it the waterbed and
that bed is the whole reason we're here
it's sensuous it's like taking your bed
to bed with you Charlie Hall invented
water bends
I I currently own three waterbeds
Charlie created a counterculture
alternative back in the 70s
remember the 70's and fern bars it was
like for the groovy people right you're
too young for fern bars in the 80s they
were as mainstream as they can get you
could walk into any store in America and
buy a waterbed how groovy is that at
their peak more than 1 in 5 of the beds
sold in the United States were filled
with water but it all started with a
novel idea Charlie had when he was in
grad school in the late 60s he had an
assignment to analyze and improve human
comfort so I talked to physical
therapists and doctors and a whirlpool
bath came up as a frequently mentioned
item about soothing temperature and
water Charlie's first prototype was a
chair filled with jello but there was a
problem that was a three hundred pounds
and not terribly practical around your
living room unless you had a forklift so
Charlie switched gears and focused on
beds the bed evolved into a water-filled
chamber I discovered very quickly you
needed to compensate for the temperature
so he added temperature control and when
he should these time into the class
everybody loved it and they couldn't get
enough of it and guess what Charlie got
an A the original waterbed Benton I
applied for a patent
shortly after I developed the product
and
got a sensor was going to be a success
charlie is still a self-proclaimed water
man this is Charlie's view this is his
boat and this is Charlie with his latest
invention
inflatable kayaks that store in the
trunk of your car and paddle like a real
nice boat okay that's great back to
water bits the Second Coming is upon us
the new version will follow the old
water bed of the water
pun intended yes one intended
you